Tyler Perry he's gonna be in a lot of
Hall of Fame's before his lifetime is
over he's taking on a new challenge
streaming the energy streaming the
entertainment icon is the mastermind
behind dozens of movies plays and TV
shows that includes two new series on
our sister network DET sisters is one in
the Oval is another Perry recently made
his first deal with Netflix for the
movie it's called a fall from grace he
directed produced wrote and co-stars in
this movie that's what he does he tells
the story of grace water she's a woman
charged with her husband's murder her
only hope for vindication lies with a
young public defender who has never
tried a case hi my name is Rory Carell
um Jasmine's boss and I think that she's
been giving you some misleading
information like you to understand
something my officers who looked at your
case up and down we think a plea is a
good idea that way you can be near your
son I know that's important to you yes
so my purpose here today is to find out
if it's still your intention to plead
guilty
as waters as it your intention to plead
guilty you play a jerky boss by the way
we're gonna talk about the twists and
turns because for people who think they
know how this is gonna turn out they
don't but I want to start with it's your
first movie with Netflix yeah
how did you choose him because you could
have gone to many studios well I have a
studio yeah well I shot it and then I
showed it to them they're like we really
really want it and but one of the things
that I loved about it I walked into the
room to have my first meeting with him
and I've never seen that kind of
diversity in Hollywood sitting around
the table ever woman I mean women every
race every sex all represented around
the table I felt so welcomed and so at
home so Big Ups to Netflix just for the
diversity that I saw when I walk in that
room you also tweeted out this picture
of the poster for the film in Times
Square yes you said and you say you have
no idea how happy this makes me
yeah well not only for me but for
Krystle Fox who has been in the business
for 40 years and yes it's our first
leading role in big break so I'm so
excited for her why did you give her the
big break
oh she's extremely talented and hadn't
had that chance and I think that this
woman could act in scenes with Denzel
Washington and Viola Davis and Meryl
Streep she is that good why do you think
it took so long for her to get that
leading role and then bigger picture are
there not the opportunities that there
should be for people of color in this
industry how much time do we have a
little bit I think that in the industry
you know as things are changing it's as
they're training to changing very slowly
but I think it's gonna take more people
like me who are taking the bull by the
horns entrepreneurs are setting up their
own shops to be able to give more
opportunities to people like this who
deserve it but here we are Tyler
thinking about oscarssowhite
in 2020 yeah I thought it was only two
or three years ago when we had that
first conversation but it was 2015 yeah
so are you surprised maybe you're not
surprised that we were still having this
conversation what did you make of the
Oscar nominees I'm not I was you know I
think that Jennifer Lopez should have
been recognized I think that I'm Athena
should have been recognized absolutely
just but but I don't have an opinion of
it either way there as I said before
build your own table but you don't have
to keep asking someone to sit it there's
yeah I think that the Academy has
try to invite more people of color into
the voting process going that well there
I think it's 16% people of color and
like 30-something percent yeah well yeah
yeah so we'll see what happens you know
after this round I don't know man III
I'm down Atlanta doing my own thing god
bless them I just I don't even want to
focus on it I want to let it go yeah and
I want to I want to encourage everybody
else to be owners entrepreneurs that
take the bull by the horns become more
producers writers and direct you made
this movie in five days five days how do
you do that I've got this amazing team
that we have a shorthand nighttime
dramas take seven days to shoot we shoot
one in a day and a half so you know and
I sit down I write it we shoot it it's
just a great I didn't learn in the
system of Hollywood so I don't know how
to do it that way I only know hide your
own way the way that I've learned to do
it so where did your idea come from this
movie because here she is accused of
murder it appears to be an open-and-shut
case she gets a public defender who's
never tried a case before I wouldn't
want that person representing me if I'm
tried for murder and it takes so I can't
get over the plot twist that happened
one right after the other I'm fascinated
by your brain type of parent where did
this idea come from I just wanted I had
always done this story boy meets girl
girl gets a heart broke and then there
she wants revenge I've always done that
story so it's like I got to do something
different and as I was writing this I
saw a documentary called Gideon's army
about public defenders I thought oh why
don't we introduce that element and
what's it like to direct yourself
because as I said you don't play a very
jerky guy do you getting the character
then you say cut and then you have to
say you ever give yourself a pep talk in
the middle of shooting a scene no I'm
not worried I just want to connect with
the other actors if they're if they
believe me then I've done what I'm
supposed to do so I'm always looking for
truth and when I play it back for myself
aside like do you like do you believe
what you just did yeah that's my that's
my game so last time we saw you we were
at Tyler Perry studios which is an
amazing place what has been the reaction
from Hollywood about Tyler Perry studios
it's been pretty quiet you think they're
scared of you no I know I don't think
that at all what do you think it's been
really I haven't heard anything I don't
know what that means of what the
reaction has been but for the people who
were there are the people who get it
they know that it's something special in
something major for someone to pull this
off an individual yeah
individual color you add all of that to
it they know that it's something special
and I'm grateful for it all right but
right now it's Charley Perry not a
Netflix more to come with the two of you
with the two brands well you know I have
B et plus which I know you did my own
streaming service I'm part owner in so I
love working with Netflix we'll see what
happens going forward whatever you want
to do it will happen for you yeah Thank
You Tyler Perry you got a really busy
day you can watch a fall from grace on
Netflix starting when Friday 17
you